joining me for today's options inside is
Kevin Kelly's chief investment officer
at what's your firm Kevin recon capital
thank you recon Capital Partners I
should have remembered that Kevin you
know we seem to be definitely in the
good news is bad news area today with
three economic reports this morning
beating estimates yields going up in the
bond market and stocks going down I mean
it's that pretty much the read here yeah
everything's trading in a macro view
right so if we look at all the options
volume and where the trading is going
it's really in the sp500 the Russell
2000 as well as VIX and you can see
there's investor demand for that because
the feds bit has their put you know
enacted since 2008 so if we look where
volumes are it's in those three indices
and the CBO we actually just released
weekly options on the Vics as well as
two new ETFs vxu pv xdn which give you
access to spot VIX so you're seeing a
lot of demand for these macro trades as
opposed to an individual named so that's
what's really happening in the
marketplace but you say there's also a
case we made that you should be watching
capital flows in this market explain to
me what you mean by that what we mean by
that is is we're seeing where all the
capital is flowing macro y so out of the
United States over in Asia over to
Europe right so we look at the Capitol
fro flows with the boon rising right so
everybody was getting out of the boond
you know even though the ECB is
implementing their quantitative easing
so it's not macroeconomic news as
driving as the capital flows and the
markets because liquidity is out there
so people are placing their bets it's
just a matter of where it is going I
want to talk about your individual trade
today because given the sort of
choppiness that we're seeing on the
macro level you are looking to google in
this market how are you playing it and
then let's dig into why yeah google is a
best in breed class name right but they
don't actually pay out a dividend to
shareholders but tech is such a strong
space and Google is a stable name that
people can feel really comfortable about
so what we're looking to do is to sell
actually two percent out of the money
call option against Google especially
because you know they've reported
earnings it's been out there you can go
out one
and actually generate about 1.3 percent
one-point-four percent and actually
bring that in while you still get a two
percent upside move and the name and
this this trade is actually off of a
CBOE index the bx y which actually has
outperformed the sp500 the Treasury
indexes so it's a stable index and you
can actually start using that strategy
to apply to individual names you feel
comfortable with okay and so what do you
get out of it in the end so what you get
out of it is you still owe you you own a
name that you want to have exposure to
so you want to own google Tech is is one
of the best spots to be in the market
right now but for the next month you
don't think there's going to be much
news we're in a low volatility
environment so what you want to do is
sell a call by Google sell a call
against it bringing that one-point-three
percent inconsistently just sell that so
you can turn Google into a bond or
dividend player depending on how and
what it was specifically which are you
buying in which you Sally so we're
buying Google here at this price and we
were looking to sell before the sell-off
this morning the 550 strike you get
about seven dollars for that adjust it
down to just two percent out of the
money and then you can do the trash and
we're at about five thirty one right now
also just wanted to quickly ask you
about a stock that's in the news today
that is charter now that the news is out
there and that it's buying time warner
the stocks actually been rising today
what's happening in the options market
so what's happening in the options
market is actually going into comcast
because comcast was the loser
essentially in this whole time warner
trade and there's you're starting to see
people actually sell some puts as well
as by some calls because it's a cheaper
value name and they have been executing
well so comcast is really the big player
it's a great name people want exposure
to and that's where the options activity
is going into interesting okay comcast
the underdog that's not something or the
value that's not something you hear
about too often I should mention charter
has turned lower now trading lower by
about half 1% Kevin Kelly recon Capital
Partners thank you so much